brutto ha signore con noi scusa di voi
posso andare non me ne frega di odio ma
più sai che cosa hanno fatto
ciao ragazzi benvenuti erano puntate
vita buttata oggi mi faccio un tè con i
the show ragazzi che bello aver di qua
che allora era servito intanto valvola
mia rondine 3d la guarda chi c'è chi c'è
dai vieni quadri di quasi non puoi darmi
come questa con la faccia in avanti
quindi non fai l'effetto morto
è vero la tua joe e anche fico se stai
leggermente così fai così è però sta in
avanti però così
c'è una cosa che voglio dire ai ragazzi
ragazze ti prego siate buoni sono due
etero cis gender bianchi che faranno del
merito al fatto che tu abbia assunto
come siamo piantine senza né come ci
identifichiamo ma ragione tu come stai
messo dal col reggi non reggini non
regge niente
tutta la verità infatti sta per
aggiungersi vodka
quando
questo qui è tutto analcolico allora ok
brutto etero signore ha in tutto questo
ma nel sit and go race avete presente su
youtube che poi fatevi fare non facciamo
assenza si può fare se si possa venire
un caso arriverà questo
una tripla
bacardi breezer all'arancia queste qui
infatti lo voglio chiamare the shock tu
sei sicuro che sia potabile poi questa
un cina e 12 lancio di rilanciare cerca
una punta di vita buttato nel caso le
parate maiale lancia possono
massaggiarla per capire se posso dire
questa frase quella è
una puntatina fa schifo ragazzino a
cagare
una parola testa a ok partiamo con una
puntata di vita buttata un po kringe sta
cosa viene resa voi kleen ger st tetto
dal cisco mai fatto un corso da bar ma
non si vede comunque un vestitevi
renault e cazzo questo è il the shock e
ragazzi l'egitto dire per
quest'anno nei migliori beach club il
vestito ragazzi
quando dice così perché sembra in
[ __ ] cioè io volevo sembrare un
[ __ ] forse separiamo [ __ ] che
non volevano sembrare quindi poi dopo io
direi che a questo punto siamo pochi
benvenuti in una nuova puntata
lo faccio io lo faccio ai ragazzi
esempio abbassa non se ne è capace
partiamo con una puntata di vita buttata
[Musica]
se no te ne remo
che secondo me non è male ma io mi sento
questo e bullismo al mio e vendetta
niente è stata quella me dopo sette anni
di relazione tossica in cui sono stata
aggredita verbalmente
denigrata e tramite
asta racconta lo rappresenta la vita
sono temi a cui tengo tra l'altro
di fornire lui c è lui ragazzi che sia
chiaro non stiamo ridendo per la
relazione tossica anzi un tutore di
commentarlo nemico esci fuori
savi così sullo stomaco è normale perché
ogni nostra non penso anche perché non
le
ascoltiamo nord di questa cazzo di
visita al meno 1 sentiamolo problemi per
un tema importante che mi sono messo a
ridere però micheli così gli dai un po
di serietà comunque sono temi importanti
ragazzi c'è una ragazza che sta cercando
di aprirsi con noi in cui sono stata
aggredita e
derubata e tra vita
passata a carico del
[Musica]
in questo
va bene
no un passo indietro perché ora mi viene
da ridere non ci sono ci sono ci sono lo
faccio io guardo su e guardo in camera
quando il fondo del bicchiere
ancora finché non vedo
passato
la sezione adesso siamo sposati dopo un
anno
come cazzo sposarti dopo un anno cioè la
prima domanda che mi viene proprio
spontaneo presente che l'amore non ha
tempi in questo momento di sposarsi dopo
un anno no è meno disposte tribunale no
non mi è mai capitato
posso dire che ha mai colpito un'altra
cosa di questo audio il fatto che lei
abbia
svilito
il sacramento del matrimonio si è
sposata per vendere ciò che viene fuori
da questa ordinanza non siamo questo
messaggio insieme questo viaggio ci
mette tanta diciamolo è una bella
lezione del karma male come facciamo a
sapere che l'approccio
cercano di quanti discorsi un cielo e
grandissima stima è gratis imam visita
la testa c'è anche un margine che cosa e
dove scusate ma comunque a me piaceva
l'avevo fatto un ragionamento me sarebbe
chiaro messaggio
con le gambe incrociate con me
perché mi da quell'idea capito che sono
mio odio rilasciate da una volta ho
fatto una mascherina del corpo di averle
prese tutte e di aver vinto un po più di
500 euro dopo di che esco per
festeggiare a far serata sera mi rubano
la borsa e nella borsa sarà questa
schedina del giorno dopo avere dovuto
incassare ci godo posso
io sono contro c'è gente che spende
soldi né scommesse poi allungare
problema che andrebbe debellato e
l'italia perchè sacco italiani si
giocano la pensione tutte le mattine
delle slot machine e nessuno fa lungo
noi che mai giocato a le schedine di no
mai non è vero ha anche vinto che vanta
vicane superiore di milioni di euro
che falso di fermare
perché
mar bingo no anale cazzo discrimine
allora il bingo e invece lo prescrive il
medico e sociale
fatico a morire è perfetto che imbarazza
ltte indacoo torino più giocato un cazzo
perché detto questo conta non è vero
neanche questo passati all'inter 8 in
quartiere veronese mandati siamo dati da
un casinò gelo tra l'ente vanta più di
soldi è chiusa ma il cazzo dice
curatissimo con una tecnica molto
facendo uno che dà la prima falla
invettiva contro giocato
tecniche che non è la prima cosa da dire
come visto la tecnica è sbagliato
con estremo orgoglio che non
pubblicizzare mai nessuna roba inerente
le scoperte che questo questo scampolo
di roma l'attore romano più famoso della
mendola amendola mi fa pubblicità il mio
traduco capito
la carriera altissima e questo quella
roba lì perché per soldi tutto ha un
prezzo per me no però 15mila euro pari a
10 milioni se lo faresti qui
semplicemente poi un prezzo quanto di
amendola che non sapevo ma si sa prima è
detto che non giochi d'azzardo e ben
venuto fuori che giocavi ha detto una
cosa che non farei mai per un attimo
dopo
che mi faresti mai negato vita non farei
mai
ma in mezzo cosa mi avete messo
avevo una speranza magari anche di avere
una carriera politica fra 10 15 anni
sapete cosa
io so più
ma che cazzo dici che ti eri come le
persone dice molto lunga sul vostro
apporto lavorativo perché coi piedi
di solito lavoriamo così ci mettiamo a
cucchiaio che partoriamo le idee capi
ultrà sono scomodo così dove
sto fissando boss stare dov'è il bagno è
quello che ci sono due sedute mi
dispiace per quello che è successo
veramente io non
do anche perché per io non ho
assolutamente anche lui e del fatto che
lui come me non beviamo alcor
evidentemente siamo fisicamente
predisposto in modo diverso o io ho
improvvisato bo meter o no a un certo
punto dalla così
[Musica]
questo è il gioco nonché in assoluto io
non volevo fare io ho proprio muoio voi
lo sapete io muoio a fare determinate
cose tra queste cose si sono intanto gli
scherzi non c'era il mondo
del
scherzi
il gioco di oggi si chiama alfabetico
voi dovrete e mi ci metto anch'io fare
un discorso una conversazione con la
persona all'altra parte iniziando dopo
le pause con lettere dell'alfabeto
la tua rubrica
ma non dal numero 10 con il mio numero
ma vado a caso sulla tua rubrica apparsi
però ci voglio più dentro
no no no si celi un altro vai a caso
quando sarà uguale anche nel prossimo
per questo molto riservata non è giusto
perfetto no no ragazzi mi state
veramente uccidendo con quest'area
stamina facciamo così facciamo così un
numero lo dico da mister è rotto i
[ __ ] poniamo mi sto sentendo ai
ragazzi sto per avere un colpo
apoplettico
allievo
della zisa lessio a nek chi twitta
singola
style dagli per tutto bene ma chi sei
e tutto prima lessio a rischio che di
camignone fi
sigliano
un gran grazie al cazzo mi stai piano
per il cerba la mente non ti ricordi di
me non è salvato il numero no
scusami davvero perso un sacco di numeri
e non ho memoria di nomi da aiutami che
i cognomi nomi letto ho voglia di
aiutarti a te stigliano aliano ma il
marito numero forse lo siamo conosciuti
io no io non ho sbagliato numero come tu
sei pietro giusto piero piero
aspetta lavoravi con
muccino
[Musica]
mammamia scusami non volevo disturbare
oddio che figura di merda porca vacca
quanto è merda rotte stronzo che sono
stato sito scusa scavalca
sì grazie ciao scusa
[Applauso]
un cazzo
innanzitutto non so che sia un simile e
un sincero ha detto no ragazzi non ce la
faccio non voglio sapere non lo voglio
vedere non voglio sapere niente di voi
no no no a caso è sì sì che va subito
che c'è nella rubrica ma dove vip a caso
no no no no il suo greggio no ma
protezione
regione lazio del giudizio delle jam oh
no no non puoi l ex storico non puoi
cosa fa nella vita devi darmi un
paradiso perché se non sono né piano
piano dove abita no no no queste sono
così io sono in combutta vuoi che dica
al pd mi costruisco un discorso magari
credibile credere che ci sia un provino
del pianista al un pianista perfetto a
posto no non puoi non puoi aspetto
smetterò sono del piero
che non risponde a un cazzo come me
arrivederci arrivederci buongiorno
chiama brancaccio direzione artistica
del brancaccio evidentemente noi cercava
un pianista mi hanno fatto il suo nome
francamente mi piacevano le le sue
referenze
giustamente la persona che mi ha parlato
di lei
e guglielmo
ho avuto delle ottime referenze da parte
sua la come farsa che come
candidatura diciamo infatti la chiamo
meritevolmente ha la possibilità di fare
uno spettacolo
non si tratta in uno spettacolo classico
o meglio potrebbe trattarsi in uno
spettacolo un po avanguardista quindi
rimarrei sul vago con lei sa non posso
dirle tutto
[Risate]
[Musica]
sarà qui a time qui nulla di ancestrale
una serata verso mezzanotte zorro
zorro
è diciamo l'opera e zorro
io posso ricominciare noi
parlo io tra tutti i numeri nella mia
rubrica e.on ha scelto te guarda che
vogliamo intanto ci ha parlato benissimo
del tema fai silenzio ma siamo qui nel
tuo canale le correlazioni la made in
italy questo comunque siamo riusciti
anche a ragazzi ha dato il call tra
queens
per lo zorro c6 ma purtroppo non c'è
nessuno spettacolo la malattia che
antonio catricalà
lasciamoli soli
andiamo parlando a moratti
sì sì sì restiamo tranquilli
e per un vita buttata con i the show che
sono quei due quelli che fanno
l'iscrizione persone presenti che si
chiamano area reti fatte lab e pon pon
che
io non cioè minuti illimitati e bassi
come
hai visto non succede niente la fenice
di grazie
a me tocca teddy e non ti ragazzi fare
una camminata era detto molto semplice
chiama questa persona poi qualcuno mi
male dice non ha mai una persona
squisita
lasciamogli di qualche minuto ma
[Musica]
allora marco
buonasera mi sente vi sentite c'è
qualcuno
di vino
è presente qualcuno mi sento francesca
non lo so provato a chiamare guardi non
so se mi sente perché è partito e santo
in sottofondo un audio o la sua
attenzione pronto pronto non so se
chiudo potevi farlo tutto senza crederci
avanti una volta però cielo signori ce
lo chiede chiama senza paura fa poker
arancione però no
cazzo sei un modello più c'era è
facilissimo adesso ho letto una tua
pagina dubbio
mi ha fatto davvero
ha messo giù proprio basta basta bisogna
andare a cena io preferisco prende il
punto perché adesso non sta più
diventando piacevole per me ma nella
vita quando è un problema fugge lo
affronti finalmente
forse questo è il partner sempre in cui
mi ha parlato quindi persona che ha
l'ansia come il faro tutti perfetto
davanti all'ansia fugge una volta che si
rilancia non è vero io ho provato a
chiamare di vino terre ma non mi ha
risposto oppone da chiamare aranzulla e
non ha risposto cioè mi sta
incominciando pian piano a salire sempre
di più l'ansia
ma io non sono questo
quale sei questo vai andiamo avanti e
non respira in un secondo i problemi con
l'ansia dello scherzo e loro lo sanno
perché io non voglio che mi vengono
fatti gli scherzi miste un'ansia folle
allora confessiamo una cosa una persona
tra loro ai nomi senza avere nomi che ha
tradito che ci ha chiesto espressamente
venite per favore fate uno scherzo
guglielmo durante la puntata noi per
rispetto della tua ansia ci siamo
rifiutati anche perché l'unità di merda
anche perché la graziano
perché la fate finta di litigare ma
scusa cioè uno dei due lasciava il set
che non se ne andava incredibili sono
stazioni di kelly di un'importante le
cacce verso dice che tu ci avresti
creduto rimpiangiamo non averlo fatto
però la grazia nei quali facciamo finta
che tu hai creduto questo scherzo
è una cosa
lo spagnolo piangere
qualcuno
997 guglielmo mai se
avete la puntata siamo quasi a
due rigirato mai banale siamo solamente
a chiudere tutti
ma non mi dice che c'e da dare alla una
storia di turandot dai facciamo una
legge che ascoltate capito cosa se no
cioè
valeva qualcuno te
io devo fingere essere imbarazzato tutto
invece
lo so io adesso vado a dirglielo gu però
non tutte le facce di coro di
no ma tra di loro prima stessero
scherzando infatti all'inizio pure viso
g sta venendo un attacco di panico no
grazie a loro hanno iniziato a litigare
non so perché all'improvviso
si è all'improvviso il mio nome
stanze con
non lo so non lo so che non lo so
non lo so ma non hanno mai fatto così
lory cons
preso malissimo
così
adesso diventa prima volta perché siete
professionisti
casa per disco del globo e vi sedete
alcune t mobile che hanno spesso somma
va bene va bene mai
abbiamo chiarito comunque adesso finiamo
la puntata e ciò detto operazione questo
un po
finiamola comitato ha le
possiamo dirti una cosa
sola detto il fasto scherzo
organizzato da terenzio ma questo è il
tuo scherzo ma va a cagare
ma ecco i nuovi scusa primo
e non so se non è semmai mi sembra che
ha più confini del mors montane
a posto
non mi interessano
non m'interessa posso andare non me li
odio ma tu lo sai come storico gli
scherzi che mi fanno dire l'ansia sempre
avendo un attacco di panico mentre
stefano mi fate lo scherzo
di non uscire
scusate non è più
no no no
ma tu lo sai che non esiste lo scherzo
innocente tu lo sai mi conosci meglio di
cinque altro e fai st cacata dopo che al
telefono nel in attacco di panico quasi
per fare lo scherzo a sori divino otelma
che aranzulla c'è di rafah ma c'è
scritto fronte
hai fatto lo scherzo perfetto hai riso
ecco qua andiamo noi vediamo come freno
solista puntata
grato mi conosci tu mi conosci punto
persone
attraverso alessandro delle miniere di
oro ma pensate cosa hanno fatto
ma lo sai che cosa hanno fatto e la
beffa ci due volte
come sta richiama forse il divino terme
in tutto questo non
esiste ha detto venuto più scherzo
ride a tutto questo era il divino otelma
questo
allora buonasera
buonasera carlo corbucci di vino
e carlo corbucci
faccio il faccio casting per goliath che
è un nuovo canale satellitare o
praticamente in gestione la sezione
artisti interesse lasci vues
manipulation praticamente
una nuova sezione di questo canale come
netflix praticamente non so se è
presente
scarsamente affidabili pronto pronto non
me la sento bene siccome di quando in
quando telefonano persone
questo va benissimo certo certo certo
questo non è un problema
e allora parti
quelle
rappresentate poi sito ti posso chiedere
per favore il sito dove lo posso scusi
una domanda
con la notte in tutti i posti
scarsa lunotti minuta ma questi non
emergano
sono tipo le dieci e mezza di notte
io non ce la faccio più 22 22 esprime il
desiderio io ti voglio fuori qua
quindi ringraziamo i the show per questa
bellissima partecipazione non avverrà
mai più
e niente ragazzi noi come sempre ci
vediamo sempre qui ma non so quando
aggiungere una cosa tu sei tornato
sobrio sul nostro che era riuscito un
video dove facciamo degli scherzi a roma
ai romani e ha partecipato anche in
maniera molto anche tranquilla andatelo
a vedere una volta tagliato prendiamo il
guanciale e lo facciamo rosolare per 10
minuti in padella ma scusi ad accendere
per caso come lo verso il
sì so se non fare ai romani venite
scrivere ma non mi ricordo qua sotto 105
dai ciao ciao
e
[Musica]